it's Universal universes Universal space
HQ
I prefer explorers to UM electric
boogaloo were you getting the vibes
urban explorers vomit well any time a
kid builds a spaceship I automatically
think of explorers but you don't steer
you don't see it that often and I I
don't know if it's just I love the idea
of doing that or I just really like the
movie explorers but that movie is
amazing ya know there's something about
like just had never seen Explorer watch
it now yeah it's a great mortgage like
flight of the navigator the last act
gets correct but but no it's really
proper Picardo and it was very much an
80s boys team a trope movie button uh if
there's just something about actually
building like your own you know fantasy
they wanna be a spaceship or whatever
net you're going into space and they
have all the gears oh there's someone
like pearl them well actually now that
I'm thinking about they had the aliens
up and say yeah okay I guess it is
explorers but um no I like cuz I'm I'm
arrows kind of you know laughing like oh
yeah I gotta make a spaceship out of all
that stuff but then we kind of see how
they do it with like you know I like how
the keyboard is sort of the directions
and like the torn-up chair yes the you
know is what they're sitting on and
stuff and yeah I just I loved all of it
and I almost I want to see more what
it's even like more the buttons and the
gears and what was one of what they used
for the stuff so yeah I don't know
there's just something you love about
that kinda thought it was all enchanting
but for me the evidence is mounting it's
building I got a whole file going here
cuz now we've got abduction in the last
yeah pretty much kidnapping yep the
father says clearly you ain't going and
then pearl pretty much is like Steven
you're going and not only that I stole
all of the shit from your dad's van the
fuck well I what here's a big kind of
rebel nearly gets them killed
I lied an well and a big revelation
that's like I'll bring it back in 50
years I didn't even think about this but
I guess everything's on earth I guess
because you can't assume the traveling
different
I mentioned in different worlds or
something but it's all got to be on
earth cuz they seem all different
dimensions on earth cuz I maybe by me
here's the thing they live on a beach
where there's this giant statue oh and I
guess it could all I mean yeah yeah I
just always assumed they were going to
different planets and shit yeah but I'm
just faster I'm like I guess the grass
is always greener cuz for pearls she's
like and Here I am stuck on earth I'm
like oh no using that warp system
Earth's still pretty fucking cool well
but you don't know what she's come from
either I mean obviously that's kind of
like her whole the rover possibilities
have you're stuck in one place of course
at the end she learns to like it but you
have me um I did like how they book
ended the show with that I would start
off with yes and I have you but it's
kind of sad and then at the end she's
like yes and I have you and I've learned
to accept that because I nearly got us
killed Kenna can Japan get working on a
crying breakfast friends show that I'm
shitting they are I'm serious they
already have it it's called cocoa pod
have you ever seen it it's the same
price again II know it's the sad piece
of burnt toast
oh you pray about that gets drunk on
milk he drowns his sorrows and milk and
gets a drunk on it and mostly episodes
is him like saying they're going oh I'm
so sad I'm burnt that all the other
pieces of bread get eaten a big hunk
toast
I want sad breakfast friends he says the
next back they live Edberg was just
either a wine that was so fight the
apple with the one arm ah it just the
cries themselves are so funny why cuz I
when he's first see those stickers I'm
like you puts a little sad face it's
like whatever a pancake or something and
I'm thinking like who makes sad stickers
and they says they're sad breakfast
friends figures okay let's go fight but
then you see the show and that's that's
hilarious this so sad breakfast is when
you wanted about us and you get kicks
instead this is for Grape Nuts know
though is when you want pop-tarts but
you get like the cinnamon one or some
nasty one that like tastes awful
are no nasty pub - oh there are there
are some nasty you know
there's some nasty ones uh um but no I I
like I don't think I've ever met a pop
tarted and like hey I'll check you out
but I also had to tell judge um after
the duct tape yeah um but uh no I really
like this one I get its Pearl is growing
on me more and more I mean this is an
episode world I told you I've always
liked pearl no no there's something I
mean I didn't Disney always garnet
amethyst and they're cool but there's
something about pearls ability to fix
vans and build a spaceship well no just
oh really
I know just how precise she is and the
calculations and stuff in it I guess
instead of being like controlling your
shirts you see more the determination of
it which I kind of like you know at
first it so you know no cuz our
calculations don't have to be a no you
can't win anything no you can't make up
anything and I know it's something like
this yes with you humans a monkey and
the dog can go to space yeah um and yeah
and you obviously see how much getting
to like you know but his face again
means and what she came from it was a
big part of her identity and her home
and everything but now she has and also
I get up an interesting point which is
how long do gems live we got the base a
little sense of year yeah it's a
thousands of years and then but this
brings up a point
I'll return Stephen in 50 years is he
can age will he stop aging at some point
when he hates lies all rail not they're
in their mid 20 like they've got a van
ain't they all look like I'm staring at
garnet right now pause on the television
like anywhere from 25 to 33 like this
stuck in that age range somewhere so is
Steven gonna hit that point like
anywhere from 25 to 33 and just stop
aging and if so is he's a jam and
apparently so well how long would even
take to get there I mean he could look
like that for like maybe a couple
hundred years and then you know suddenly
you know grow a mustache sure and if
they're practically immortal how do they
not abuse that power
who says they're not exactly I'm telling
them the evidence is building um but
yeah I like the it's a good pearl Steven
episode it's uh I love like I said the
building the spaceship thing it's just
something I always liked and I love the
dad at the end this this kid is killing
me yeah I love when he just goes in the
fetal position I like you just
sympathise that's what I'd say if like
oh my god yeah no you just sympathized
with it
um what and I you do even though you
know they're not gonna go away and he's
not gonna come back in 50 years you do
kind of feel that urgency cuz pearl is
just so sad and here we go no no there's
no problem it's like no no you really
have to rationalize fast that this is a
bad thing uh you know that fifty years
is a long time he'll probably be dead by
that point you know we can't do this no
no go go I don't have 50 years I feel so
bad words that how do you file that
Amber Alert ah no my son's been abducted
by a gem they built a rocket ship at you
know and I'll check myself into the
aside no I kind of handed him over
willingly no I didn't really hand him
over she just stole all the ship for my
van and macgyvered a spaceship and now
she's flying to the nearest star system
why wasn't he in love I don't know um
but again that does sir raised even more
questions like this is all on earth I
mean is this is this kind of like the
future or something like that or what
happened to make the earth kind of look
this way back to the future ii did not
predict this no um there's a great
meeting that says can we remake back to
the future too and it's just everybody
looking at their phones and getting
offended by everything bad that's my new
favorite offensive fri yeah actually no
ROI just dealing with everybody my job
is offending those people now regrets um
but yeah I thought this was uh why do
you think every episode of Steven
universe has to have a moral hey you
miss the world on this episode of Steven
uh I really like this I found some good
balance of like you know creativity with
the spaceships or the emotional with
pearl and Steven even the father as well
uh it doesn't
you know immediately connect to like the
continuing story but it does drop these
little hints out like hey but you didn't
know that but you didn't know this and
it's I was enough feeling more shit yeah
and it does it very naturally can add to
the FB i--'s file so um yeah it I don't
know I really like this one I like this
one better than the last one I mean I
like the relationship with Steven his
damn the last one but um I I somehow
felt it even more when I felt it more
than a killers what that cuz he was
scared shitless yeah and you just you
really developing like the fucking
Challenger and explode he's a Coney shit
yeah and it's one of those things where
when you hear it happening I mean you
just sort of sympathize with that rush
like no no this is like you get a little
panicky too even though you know
nothing's gonna happen you know like
he's got come back we have several
episodes of stuff but you feel that
panic cuz it's just happening so quick
and it is such a different world it's a
totally different person to rationalize
with because they do have different you
know age growth and everything um I
would I watch the next one Wow
say goodnight Gracie it's never an
embarrassment to bail there's a lot of
time where's bad to fail baddest like oh
yeah I got the high my new we are gonna
get into this no no I I don't need to go
into like deep details i but you know
there's bad sight there's plenty of my
time to watch the next episode am I good
I think I got him done
no I'm just saying that it's like you
know how about bail when it's needed
when you need to do I don't like let's
just there's no shame in bailing but
it's should establish I don't know I can
see just so many feel like just sitting
on a couch I'm not getting a jar like
goes through all the jobs they went
through and then they just quit the
Nexus no sure even billing holding some
kid over a cliff trying to save them
yeah there's no shame in bailing I mean
as unlikely as that is I think it's
weird I mean I think most people would
get and my most kids would get it but
it's still like you know I I don't know
I can see someone just running that
message through their head like at an
important moment or something like that
misinterpreting it or something
so some kids taken a test as go well no
shame in bailing and just gets out of me
about what were you thinking son Steven
universe told me I uh you know I'd be
lying if I said I didn't think the same
thing but then I have to wonder am I
thinking too much like an adult now like
oh well the pitch is chilled into the
fridge oh it was it when I was a kid I
want to be a lot actually in school it's
maybe that is or maybe that's our
problem is we're thinking too much about
what we were as kids but maybe we were
just jackass kid Oh kids are jackass
kids you know baby particularly we were
here especially Jen maybe we don't
really ask what if we if we existed you
know there's others that existed but it
is true we were always the class
fuck-ups yeah but maybe I don't know um
I think they come at just a little bit
more like if it's when it's needed or
what it's necessary as well you know
what but we bailed on that and here we
are as grown adults watching cartoons
now I should thought more about that
speech really it's no shame in bailing
yeah uh yeah I think the best thing you
take out of this either onto something
yeah um I'm bailing and there's no shame
in that yeah there is terrible people